لا شك ان نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه ستغير
واقع الامريكيين في الداخل الامريكي في
ملفات عده سيطارها تغيير بعد هذه
الانتخابات سيماها الملفات التي شكلت نقطه
خلاف الاساسيه بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين ابرزها كيفيه معالجه تضخم
المتزايد في الولايات المتحده حيث طالما
شدد الجمهوريون على ضروره التراجع عن خطط
الانفاق الضخمه
وملف اخر قد ياخذ منحا اخر والحديث هنا عن
خطه بيض لتحديث البنيه التحتيه وهي الخطه
التي لم تلقى تاييدا من قبل الجمهوريين
واوصفك للخطه حوالي همم تريليونيه دولار
وهو المبلغ الذي اعتبره الجمهوريون الضخما
نوع اشتكى الجمهوريون من ان الخطه تتضمن
انشاء محطاته شحن لسيارات الكهربائيه اكثر
من التحديثات الماديه مثل الطرق والجسور
والموانئ
ثالث الملفات الداخليه الهامه ملف النفط
حيث ان قرار ايضا الاخير بسحب النفط من
المخزونات الاستراتيجيه لمواجهه تراجع
الامدادات لها قال رفضا كبيرا من
الجمهوريين لدرجه انهم اطلقوا في مجلس
النواب تحقيقا للنظر في اساءه استخدام
محتمله للمخزون الاستراتيجي